Stefano I need you right now are you in
here
Stefano are you in here what the [ __ ]
was that uh Stefano was that you are you
in here
oh man I finally done it I open the
portal to the other round this is
success Alexander with Emily he's use
words
blah blah blah his ingredient penis all
right that's a good ingredient wha what
no no aah no I'm so screwed
I'm so screwed I shouldn't have left the
funnel a missing so much okay okay it's
fine
wait I need to check this drawer because
there might be a key there wasn't the
key
okay it's cool I heard something over
here there's definitely something here
and there's Bettina marks okay it's fine
he doesn't know I'm here
I came here and he's right there oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay just just look over here it's
oh man oh man he's so sexy holy [ __ ] I'm
going here I think no here oh [ __ ] yes
man boobs now that makes him even more
delicious okay
[ __ ] out man boobs that's gonna lie
okay no it's not here I already been in
here so I have to [ __ ] door
ah [ __ ]
uh-uh okay it's yeah it's here he's
polite and opens doors at least like
given that okay I got it I got it I got
the orb I however I played this game and
why whoa
never mind I thought it was gonna be
like Indiana Jones moment when I put the
ball and this is awkward
I'm just gonna pick it up okay bad news
happened now no Stefano are you doing
this oh I just picked up a piece of the
yeah yeah run run run run oh why don't
wait to go cause it's cause it I love
closets
I love crosses Oh delicious of [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] guys so ugly he's so ugly I'm
just gonna go over here close the door
there's not even a [ __ ] door okay
there's the door
cake the happy place happy place happy
place happy place happy place rainbows
and unicorns haha I don't have anything
except my penis right now and it's not
feeling very ah no no no no no no no
Corner corner corner Corner corner
corner
I love corners to get the corner ready
camping in the corner what am i doing
nothing nothing at all I only
oh [ __ ] I can hear him ah he's camping
outside that's not fair I hate camping I
accept I do it myself but [ __ ] [ __ ]
Keith's camper [ __ ] bro is a camp Oh
a door sweet let's go I get the feeling
something bad is going to happen yes yes
yes where is the exit I need to find the
exit please tell me this is exit it's
not the exit [ __ ] great I don't even
know what's going on I feel like I'm a
big fan Oh many stefanos I'll take you
hello pretty you have to get out what
are you doing I'm so confused
don't trap me Stefano come with me
please please please please please the
funnel I'm glad you're here I am NOT you
are an idiot why did you pick up the
almond I'm sorry Stefan oh I'm really
confused right now
I know it was the same but it's stuck
it's stuck it's stuck
I need dining-hall key maybe no I can't
use that way maybe I can use this no I
can't use this i can use [ __ ] Stefano
tell me what the [ __ ] to do please this
sound is freaking the hell out of me
you [ __ ] know
I don't want to play anymore right now I
really don't want to so I think I'm
gonna end it here I hope you have a nice
evening I'm sad face that was so
horrible
the father did nothing nothing
this game sometimes it was I
it was door and I was like ah maybe I
can go in there and he's like how long
I'm gonna be here in the door while you
go in then yes I think something is wet
down there actually to tell the truth
but I'll see you sometime if I ever dare
to play this [ __ ] game again haha
thumbs up the video
yeah ask me what it feel like seven a
disguise so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie to say real like I'll be making
good on my promises honesty is pop it
inside of it is listen but I realized I
can't be better than I was light on my
feet
cooking up this all when we fire up